Beautiful.
So beautiful.
It's easy to cook on TV.
There's talented producers,
there's editors,
and there's all sorts of
things that make you look good.
You know, before any TV came
anywhere near my career,
I'd mastered my craft.
You'll see a side to
me across this class
that I don't think has
ever been shown before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Knife skills.
The basics are so important.
Three fingers down, and
this beautiful knuckle
is the guiding light
across that knife.
Cooking salmon.
So the secret is
to score the skin.
That stops the fish
from buckling up.
You can't pick up the
"World's Best Cookbook"
and understand it,
you need to do it.
Mm.
Delicious.
Everything that I've learned,
understood, stolen, perfected,
is laid bare across this MasterClass,
for the first time ever.
And you would learn how to cook
those ingredients from start
to finish.
I've just spent
the last 30 years
busting my ass off to
get on the plate what
I'm about to show you.
And watch, but watch
carefully.
I'm Gordon Ramsay and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]